black dragon sounds cool I know I know
that sounds so cool man that's what you
would join I don't know they wouldn't
they would know they're like this guy
ain't gonna make it
this guy's ears are cheap yeah they're
like no way bro
[Laughter]
[Music]
all right welcome back to another
amazing episode of careful boys we have
with us today Mr Johnny Chang so one of
the craziest things just happened so
when I saw this guy's photo because uh
Bart sent me the video I was like he
looks kind of familiar and I just don't
and then we just know so many of the
same people he mentioned a guy's name
that he hung out with that put him on
game with the um with the snake reptile
selling yeah right and I was like oh I
know this guy's dealer friend right
the activity
in the reptile dealer and then I was
like oh that's funny I've never met
anyone from your guys's group I've heard
of them but I never met them but then my
memory is all kind of shoddy about that
I was like
[__] 19 18 and I was always high
right
we do have a mutual friend
um that also Ryan knows another one and
then I was like in the bathroom right
now and I was peeing and I was like okay
but these people I used to hang out with
them all the time and we were in the
same area and I was like oh my [__]
God I did meet him before and we just
that's crazy remember the moment when I
introduced myself we were at our our
mutual friend's house it was the first
time I came over with our buddy uh that
starts with the N yeah
we came together Nigel
he's very Posh don't say his name Bart
yo shut up dude
Five Five Guys on this on the in the
living room that I've never seen before
there were some guys in the backyard uh
that I knew in in this house it was his
friend and their brothers
and it's in a neighborhood that that um
my buddies always ran around and then so
I went inside and um I always you know
introduced myself to people just just to
like make it like we're cool you know
and I heard that it was a group called
Monterey Park watching which it wasn't
them
but then my older buddies always hung
out with other watching members all the
time so I was like oh we're all product
probably cool right so I introduced
myself I was like what's up and he
remembers me because he described what I
looked like
and what year exactly is this again [__]
dude I don't remember this has to be
like it was when I was like probably
just got out but yeah it was around that
time yeah and he was like you were bald
you had you always wear looks yes I
actually have no these aren't the pair
it became a costume later on you watch
Just Kidding Films right when we played
like the characters it became a costume
the looks we would pop out the lenses
and it became our frames that's so funny
yeah that's so crazy the five dollar
looks bro
it's like so funny because I would wear
lobes too and they were so dark that
when I was hitting people up I didn't
even know what they look like
it would probably helped oh
where are you from
you can't even so you can't even know
who the hell it could be an old lady bro
but what if it was like just you and
your brother and you guys are just just
hey hey banging on each other you don't
even know like wait oh what the [__] oh
wait we're at home
that memory was a blur to me right like
was there like a get like a just a quick
kick back there or something that's it
was always like that bro yeah yeah kick
back they would stay there till like
five enough memory dude you can still
remember what he was wearing at them he
said you were wearing an essay jacket I
had it I was always bald I would wear my
looks like I would wear it like
backwards I would wear it here yeah
[Applause]
and then I was skin bald yeah and you're
talking the period of time that you guys
met was in the 67 days that you were in
between yeah what are the chances bro
that's what I seen him before I'm like
I've seen this that's like 2001 or like
earlier
no it was it's It's gotta be
[__] I don't know but when was this
house seven days that you were you still
underage yeah I was still young I was
what like 16 no yeah like 16 15. yeah
Joe do you remember him at all he was
19. I I was probably 19 or something
yeah yeah so oh 203 I was like 19. but
the thing is I just remember like yeah
there was five something guys just
sitting around on one side of the living
room and I came in I said what's up I
went to the backyard
and everything else is a blur like and I
remember though like that house got kind
of crazy after a while because everyone
was just doing drugs or whatever but
then the brothers got into an argument
and then the little brother shot at the
older brother with a shotgun inside the
house and after that everyone's like
don't go because the cops came yeah oh
my God nothing about that yeah
it's just rumors rumors
wait let's let's test his memory what
else was he wearing yeah oh yeah he
always he always wear a lot of black and
white I think you wore black and white
at that time probably I mean a lot of
people did but for sure had Cortez's I'm
pretty sure I don't know about that yeah
maybe but I don't know that day was a
blur but that's all I remember
um but yeah the name that you dropped I
was like that that sounds so familiar
man who is this guy and then all these
things started coming down and he was a
nut job and he was a small dude with a
bald head like real small right and he
was crazy like just the stories is like
man this guy is like a real life Child
Soldier like always drugged up always
shooting things for no reason yeah I saw
ambiguous like who is like a small like
small dude with a bald head yeah like
you know it's like that's that fits
everybody back in the 90s every gang
members description small guy imagine
probably sketching that I was a skinny
all right a circle the paper's like this
big you just draw him out the box
it's a small guy right okay next to the
other thousand small guys with the bald
head we must have been
um but you you were skinny back then
yeah I was just about to say oh I was
like 120 pounds 100 I don't remember
that yeah I was 120 pounds that's crazy
yeah it was a super skinny guy I I hit
it with big clothes big jackets stuff
like that but I knew you were Japanese
like it was like I could just tell you
know like like you weren't like you
didn't look like I mean we dressed like
essays and gamer but yeah you can tell
you know other Asians can tell other
ages Joe got that face dude you got that
Japanese face what was he wearing what
was he wearing do you do you did you was
other people my crew there or like that
I don't remember I just remember you
came up to us and was respectful yeah
yeah in a time that nobody was
respectful it was like what's up who
were you for you know everyone was you
know banging on everyone's trying to be
extra hard
I was in a um I wasn't a true Banger
dude to be honest like I I hated that
[__] I thought it was so stupid but you
look the most banged up
She was That's like me saying I I don't
I don't like tattoos guys you know it's
like yeah yeah
because by that time I was older I got
in when I was around like 15 16. yeah so
by that time I was like wait why aren't
we making money more like why aren't we
doing like because a lot of the homies
were getting into
um burglaries they're getting into those
kind of hard stuff four five nines yeah
and then I was like what we need to do
is just start selling this stuff we need
to like we need to organize better this
is too scattered we need some piranha
and another thing
that those like senseless fighting is
stupid like if you're fighting for a
purpose to make like a gain in something
like if you just it and then we have you
know every group had that hot head right
that would just start [__] and then the
rest of the homies have to finish what
they started and I'm like what's the
point of getting into these wars when
like it's so dumb so then I I think
after a while it's just like why are you
guys picking and bullying these other
groups and it's probably because I got
bullied and I'm like I don't want I
don't want to do that like we're not we
shouldn't do that like let's be an
organized group and then I was like um I
was just like I don't I just started
seeing the stupidity around like 18 19
right and then
um
after that whole you know in the
drive-by happened we saw somebody die
all this stuff and then we didn't get
any backup from our own group then I was
like why do we even need a group name so
me and my buddies that left like all the
youngsters left at once so when you do
that you can't get jumped out what are
they gonna do right and then we said
why can't we just work and do the same
things we don't need a name we don't
need a bang we need to have to dress
like we bang anymore and then that's the
mentality that started changing for us
and we stopped hanging out stopped going
to these parties stop like doing any of
that stuff yeah yeah that's crazy but
that's when our our buddy with a with
our big time Gangster buddy with a
letter N that's when he's special yeah
that's when he started hanging out with
other groups because we weren't active
in that way anymore I see yeah
the game I like the idea of being like
yeah I could tell that Joe is Japanese
he was coming in respectful and my in my
head he's just walking up just bowing to
people
man that's different dude this guy's
different shallow about it
I I was thinking we okay for one we're
not we were we weren't that big like we
weren't that big but I also knew not
many people in our Hood was down to do
crazy stuff they're down to fight
everyone's down to fight yeah everyone's
down like we had we had situations where
we would go like when we're like only
three deep and like we're just hitting
them up and there's ten of them let's go
yeah but no one's thinking is anyone
gonna die today because we're like 17
and 16. you know you don't think like
that when you're that age right and then
when you start seeing like real [__] I'm
just like okay these like these other
guys these Vietnamese Guys these these
other Cambodian guys like they're
they're real like they're out here
shooting people every day like we're
over here like [__] West Side Stories
like let's fight
you guys ready no but but for me I was I
was always like we need to we need to if
there's no beef we need to keep it cool
as much as possible so you just gotta go
up to everybody and be like hey we cool
all right cool we were probably one of
the only groups out there where like
like you know when watching Asian boys
were like beefing like we were staying
out of it but we were cool with both
sides neutral yeah because we're just
out of it and I was like let's stay
[__] out of it but other Hot Heads
just wanted to be in the mix because
they wanted a name by staying neutral
they thought that we were a [__]
because they're like we're not in the
mix that they're in that's true bro and
I'm like no that's stupid dude but that
was my mentality during that time and we
all argued about it's like no we're out
here [__] with like [__] groups we
need to go and take one of those guys
down so then they know that we're forced
to be reckoned with I'm like why rog's
friends with this side and I go to
school with Asian boys so why the [__]
would I want to be the only guy
that's my lab partner
he's a cool guy man why are you gonna
make me do this man
just imagine two thugs with the goggles
who's gonna do it first man
[Laughter]
crazy memories dude so that was that
window where you were only out for like
two months and then we we crossed paths
and then you you went right back in as
an adult yeah
wow that's crazy a knucklehead that
you're talking about yeah
you know you were the Hot Head yeah the
hot head no one of the Hot Heads you
know
like there's a lot there was a lot back
then top three hothead
but nowadays it's not like that you know
it's which is good bro honestly that's
why yeah you know they created like the
gang units for all of us too I don't
know if you guys remember the Temple
City crash units and yeah ATF and all
that crazy stuff do you remember Safari
the pool hall out in the Roland
sounds familiar so there was a pool hall
there there was another one well where
that recent shooting one was um right
here in Monterey Park where the old guy
shot the dance studio that was a pool
hall we all went to and then back in the
day when you just played you're just
hanging out with your buddies
the gang unit will come in and they'll
just round up every Asian kid that they
can find line them up against the wall
and then be like all right where you
from uh whatever they'll write you up
your full name give me your ID
I'm super familiar with Safari because
my comrades are from Hacienda Heights
so we hung out over there a lot did you
guys get pulled up on by the all the
time yeah yeah yeah it was always the
sheriff the sheriff was the game I don't
know we were at uh Carol's remember when
carols was on Valley which carols it
used to be now it's not dark
[Laughter]
it's hella good dude
we were in the middle of a meal in the
middle of a [__] meal my friend's
probation officer comes in and he goes
you come here right he goes he goes you
too and I'm all like I don't I'm not
even in trouble I'm Japanese
[Laughter]
I'm not even doing anything and I don't
know the law back then right so I go
outside I there's other cops waiting for
us
oh man same thing
well gang I'm in the middle of a male
dude I'm [__] what game are you from
whatever business is I got I got um I'm
in the record of being a part of Asian
boys because I was with one that day
such bad news not understanding the law
is like to be back then yeah they could
just get you to do anything yeah so I'm
on the record as that I'm not from that
gang but
yeah back then it was like no loss they
just grab you up and they just wanted
files they needed files building files
every day I wanted to be on a file so
bad
what about me
hey I'm that guy's friend
hey what's up Joe I'm Ryan who's this
Indian guy
oh man
that's the thing when Ellen was here we
were talking about because she had a
similar experience but in NorCal in
NorCal yeah and her experience was kind
of like mine where the odd there's like
a weird
um Paradox with like if you don't look
like you're gonna beat someone's ass
you're gonna get your ass beat like so
we had to look like to blend in like you
had to look like the people that would
kick your ass because if you don't then
it's like or like Alan was like I have
to roll with these people or they'll
beat my ass
so it's such a weird like Paradox that's
one thing that uh when I first so I I
grew up in Cerritos and I feel like it's
like a middle class neighborhood and
then so when I got kicked out and I
moved out here and when I first came to
keppel I remember seeing like just
everyone look like cholos even if you're
a nerd yeah that was the style I was
like
like I was like oh [__] this place is so
[__] Hood even the [__] Geeks are
Hood as [__] how does that mean it's
so funny it's so weird man we had dudes
from the math club wearing red laces in
their uh Chucks yeah like that what are
they doing shots in their attractions
yeah and I was like well that's how you
survive I guess well I don't know I just
think the culture like swap meet cholo
whatever like Triple A T culture was
just so big yeah I think a lot of like
other cities were kind of like like play
play banging you know and then here you
have like you know I've met friends that
were been getting jumped on their
streets since they're eight years old
they have to join so it was like the
culture was real rather than being
romanticized from a different area yeah
and there that led to a lot of innocent
people getting killed oh yeah they would
ride on people and be like oh this guy's
wearing black and red and thinking that
they're putting in work on our our
people and it's not even it's just like
regular kids yeah that was really sad
you know it's kind of yeah when you
mentioned earlier about meth I really
think that like that made a lot of kids
crazy and they were attacking like
innocent math kids just coming home from
Kumon yeah because of those reasons like
they liked Jersey or they they really
like this number or whatever and I was
like yeah
I remember like my first experience in
Monterey Park so I moved from Gardena
um and after school me and my friends
were just walking home and then a car
pulled up full of guys and then like I
never been hit up hit up before and
they're like where the [__] you from and
I'm like I just moved here from Gardena
that's a good answer though good thing
you shouted confidence you know I was
like I just moved here from Gardena and
then like I didn't know like that they
were asking me what gang I was from
and they don't like [__] you from
whatever whatever and we're like no no
no no I don't know what that is and then
come to find out the friend that was
with me his older brother is in it so he
got kind of grouped up so they
recognized him I didn't [__] know
[__] dude I was just like why are these
guys yelling at us and then they started
slamming Snapple bottles they had empty
slapple bottles hey shut up from Gardena
and then it's like raining Snapple
bottles and they're exploding and I'm
just [__] running like Oh I thought
this was a better neighborhood
oh
that was so scary
but like going through [__] like that
you feel like I'm so vulnerable I need
help I need somebody to protect me like
I need I'm scared like there's like
bottles coming and blast being exploded
around me you know yeah it's a scary
feeling right hell yeah dude
yeah for sure man first time getting
like chased by a car full of people
that's like crazy too bro
so they had like Sobe bottles back yes
so big dude
[Laughter]
that looks like fruity drinks huh
you see the flavor you're like I think
I'm good strong
men yeah
they're sitting there drinking a peach
Snapple and they're like hey you
finished with your orbits yet you know
like you've got the [__]
Sobe you know what's crazy dude what you
were saying about uh about the simulated
gang [__] too is I remember we almost
got in trouble because a dude that was
hanging with us when we worked at the
mall had lied and said he was a black
dragon and when you lied remember that
[__] like when you hear somebody's like
faking it yeah and they all just rolled
up to the mall and we had to close the
[__] oh [__] yeah yeah and we didn't
know that he was just like lying this
whole time we're like bro you could got
all of us killed yes over nothing that
gets a lot of people in trouble honestly
like because people was will claim
something and then like the other gangs
would think okay we have problems with
them yeah
like what the hell happened and then it
just from that one cause the whole thing
on the side yeah so he started a new
fight that didn't even exist because he
pretended right that's wild inherited
the beef basically and you know and he
said it to impress a girl who was like
friends with black dragon so it's like
you [__] up like he wasn't she wasn't
impressed
no black dragon sounds cool I know I
know that sounds so cool man that's what
you would joined
they wouldn't they would know that like
this guy ain't gonna make it
these guys this guy's ears are cheap
yeah they're like no way bro
[Laughter]
I could start an Asian gang generator so
there's two types you should
career the first type is you get a color
and an animal you put it together and
you go
yellow lizards
green frogs you know and then the other
one is like
something boys oh yeah you know
[__]
hahaha